[موسيقى]
الحديث عن الطاقه لا ينفصل عن حسابات
السياسه فتضارب مصالح القوى الاقليميه
والدوليه او توافقها وما يدفعه من
اضطرابات وصراعات او حتى من استقرار يحرك
تيرمومتر اسواق الطاقه العالميه صعودا
وهبوطا مما ينعكس خاصه على اسواق الشرق
الاوسط والعالم العربي فالعديد من دول
منطقه لديها احتياطيه كبرى من النفط
والغاز تصدر الى انحاء العالم برا وبحرا
نقارب الليله دبلوماسيه الطاقه او
بالاحرادبلوماسيه انابيب الغاز في شرق
المتوسط نلقي الضوء على مشروع يهدف الى
تعزيز التعاون العربي المشترك في ملف
الطاقه وتلبيه احتياجات مواطنيها
المتزايده الى الكهرباء وتحفيز اقتصاديات
الشركاء فيه مشروع ابصر النور منذ اكثر من
عقدين لنقل فائض الغاز الطبيعي المصري الى
الاردن سوريا ولبنان وتركيا وصولا الى
اوروبا في قصتنا خط الغاز العربي ن تطور
هذا المشروع وتاثره بالمتغيرات السياسيه
والامنيه والاقتصاديه في الدول المستفيده
منه خاصه بعد تفجر ثورات الربيع العربي
ادى الى تعطله قبل 12 عاما الى انجر
الاتفاق على احيائه قبل عامين فاجتماع
رباعي بين وزراء الطاقه في مصر والاردن
وسوريا ولبنان لحل ازمه الكهرباء الحاده
في لبنان ورغم ترحيب الامريكي بالمشروع
بدايه فان تفعيله اصطدم بضروره تقديم
ضمانات كافيه لاستثنائه من العقوبات
الامريكيه على النظام السوري والمتعامدين
معه كما اصطدم بعدم موافقه البنك الدولي
على تمويل جلب الغاز المصري الى لبنان
ولبحث اسباب هذا التعثر نستكمل بقيه هذه
القصه مع المهندس وائل حامد عبد المعطي
خبير اسواق الغاز والحيدروجين في منظمه
الابطال العربيه المصدره للبترول هايت
مديره معهد حوكمه الموارد الطبيعيه لمنطقه
الشرق الاوسط وشمال افريقيا نسال ضيفين
الكريمين عن مدى ارتباط الامر المتغيرات
السياسيه اللبنانيه وعمليه ترسيم الحدود
بين اسرائيل ولبنان وعن قدره مصر على
الاستمرار في ضخ الغاز عبر الخط العربي في
ضوء تقارير تتحدث عن تزايد الطلب المحلي
وتراجع التصدير وعن الفرص التي يحملها بدء
التنقيب عن النفط والغاز امام السواحل
اللبنانيه لكن بدايه نشاهد القصه وبعدها
الحوار
شهدت دول الشرق الاوسط في تسعينيات القرن
الماضي تزايدا في الطلب على الكهرباء
مدفوعا بنمو عدد السكان والنشاط الاقتصادي
في ذلك الوقت ساعد حكومات سوريا وتركيا
والاردن والعراق ومصر الى ربط شبكاتها
الكهربائيه في مشروع عرف لاحقا باسم الربط
الثماني بعد انضمام لبنان وليبيا والسلطه
الفلسطينيه اليه لكن تلك المحاولات لم
تلبي الطلب اذ وبينما سجل عدد السكان
تزايدا بنسبه
48% ونمى الطلب على الكهرباء في بلدان
المشروع من 131 ت سنه 1990 الى
432 ترواط سنه 2010 بزياده تقدر بنحو 230
بالمئه تراجع هامش احتياطي القدره على
التوليد في سوريا ولبنان والعراق من
بالمئه سنه
1990 الى سالب واحد بالمئه سنه 2010 وفقا
لدراسه
لكن فرصه كانت لوحف الافق عبر انشاء خط
لنقل فائض الغاز الطبيعي في مصر الى بلدان
الجوار عرف المشروع باسم خط الغاز العربي
ومثل فرصه لتلبيه الاحتياج ولتعزيز
التكامل بين بلدان المنطقه في ملف الطاقه
مشروع خط الغاز العربي هو احد المشاريع
الاستراتيجيه والهامه التي ساهمت في تحفيز
الاقتصاد والحصول على وقود ارخص كلفه من
الوقود التقليدي ايضا ساهمت في تخفيف
الاثار البيئيه للوقود الاحفوري
الغاز العربي
بدا في اواخر التسعينات
والهدف منه هو توثيق الصلات التجاريه بين
الدول العربيه
واتاحه المجال امام مصر لتصدير الغاز
المصري الى الاردن وسوريا ولبنان وربما
فيما بعد الى العراق
بحلول عام 2001 بدا خط الغاز العربي والذي
بلغ قطره 36 بوصه وطاقته الاستيعابيه عشره
مليارات متر مكعب من الغاز سنويا بدا يشق
الطريقه من العريش شمال سيناء الى مدينه
العقبه الاردنيه في غضون عامين ومع انجاز
مرحلته الاولى بطول 265 كلم وصلت اول
دفعات الغاز المصري الى الاردن من العقبه
وصل الانبوب طريقه شمالا الى محطه شمال
الاردن بطول
393 كيلومتر وتم ربطه بالشبكه السوريه عام
2008 ليصل قرب حمص على بعد
324 كيلو متر حيث تفرع الى محطتي بانياس
السوريه ودير عمار على سواحل طرابلس في
لبنان بحلول العام 2009 كان الغاز المصري
يسري في خط بلغ طوله 11200 فيما وصل
التكلفته الى مليار ومئتين مليون دولار
كم ربط الخط الغاز العربي مع العراق اظن
في سنه 2006 فبالتالي المنظومه هذه كانت
ممكن تستفيد من ناحيه تخفيض كره في انتاج
من ناحيه مرونه في تشغيل نظام الكهربائي
من ناحيه تبادل الطاقه الكهربائيه بين ضعف
البعض فبالتالي هذه فوائد حقيقه كان فوائد
لجميع الدول المشاركه مما شجعها على انه
تنشئ هذا الخط
حاولت دول مشروع خط الغاز العربي تطويره
وتوسيعه لتعزيز التعاون المشترك في مجال
امن الطاقه اذ عمل العراق على ربط الخط
بشبكته المحليه ووقعت الاطراف اتفاقا لمده
الى تركيا حيث تنتظره هناك فرصه واعيده
لربطه بخط انابيب المتجهي الى اوروبا
[موسيقى]
لبنان استفاد من هالمشروع من خلال مشاركته
فيه واقرار الشراكه بموجب قانون صدر عن
مجلس النواب نحن مرحلتنا اكتملت بال 2008
بالاستفاده من الغاز منها المشروع خلال
عام 2009 بنسان واستمرت الاستفاده لشهر
شباط 2010 خلال هذه الفتره تم تشغيل
مجموعه واحده بمعمل داير عمار وحققت وفر
يقدر ب 150 مليون دولار خلال سنه واحده
اللي حال دون تشغيل المرحله الثانيه هو
انه لبنان
لم يلتزم كما يجب بتامين المبالغ المتوجبه
لمصر
بالنسبه للاردن بالذات حقيقه الاردن كلفه
انتاج الطاقه الكهربائيه انخفضت الى نصف
تقريبا وهذا ساهم في تخفيف فاتوره الطاقه
الكهربائيه ايضا ساهم في انه في الامور
الاثر البيئي كمان ساهم كمان الاردن يعني
المشروع صار داخل الاردن وجميع الاعمال
المقاولات والانشاءات وغيره كمان تمت داخل
الاردن فكان له اثر ايجابي على الاردن من
ناحيه انخفاض كلفه الطاقه الكهربائيه ومن
ناحيه الاثر الاقتصادي
لمشاريع كبرى داخل الاردن
رغم الاثر الايجابي للمشروع على ملف
الطاقه في البلدان المستفيده الا ان
استمراره اصطدم بعقبات تقنيه وماليه
مختلفه فتباطا ضخ الغاز المصري حتى انقطع
عن لبنان في فبراير 2010 وعن سوريا نهايه
العام ذاته فيما استمر ضخ الغاز المصري
بشكل متقطع الى الاردن حتى منتصف عام 2013
ادى ذلك لانقطاع لازمات في الطاقه الراقه
الحكومات وضغطت على الاهالي اذ عانى
السوريون من انقطاعات متكرره في التيار
الكهربائي قدرتها دراسه لبرنامج مسارات
الشرق الاوسط بنحو ثلاثه واربعين يوما في
السنه لكن لبنان باقي في مقدمه البلدان
المتضرره وتسبب شحو موارده الماليه بعجزه
عن تامين المحروقات الكافيه
[تصفيق]
وتفاقمت الازمه بعد العام 2019 حتى تدهورت
قدره لبنان الانتاجيه من ثلاثه الاف
بيجاوات الى 600 ميجا وات
عجز لبنان بمجال الكهرباء لناحيه حاجته
وقدرته على انتاج الطاقه هي التاليه لبنان
بحاجه بفتره الذروه لحوالي 3000 ميجا واط
قبل هالازمه قبل 2019 كنا عم نوصل للالف
لما بنشغل المعامل الصالحه او المجموعات
الصالحه
وتراجعت بعد الاحداث بعد 2019 صرنا عم
ننتج يمكن 600 ميجا او اقل شوي او اكثر
بقليل
في عام 2010 وهو عام طبعا حافل بالاحداث
اللي صارت خاصه فيما يتعلق بما يسمى
بالربيع العربي تم وقف
تصدير او ضخ الغاز الى سوريا بينما الاردن
بقي فيها الغاز موجود الا انه حقيقه
بالالفين 2011 صار في تفجيرات على خط
الغاز في شمال سيناء تفجر يمكن اكثر من
عشرين ثلاثين مره وبالتالي هذا اثر على
تزويده الى الاردن
توقفت صادرات الغاز المصريه والسبب
الرئيسي لذلك هو
الطلب المتزايد داخل مصر على الغاز لم تعد
تستطيع ان تصدر كميات الغاز التي كانت
تصدرها سابقا جزء كبير منها يذهب للاردن
الاردن الاردن حقيقه في العوامل 2011 لحتى
منتصف 2015
اعانت معاناه كبيره جدا بحيث انه الغاز
تقريبا توقف تدفقه الى الاردن وبالتالي
كساره كلفه الطاقه الكهربائيه ارتفعت بشكل
كبير جدا ورتب على شركه الكهرباء الوطنيه
في الاردن ديون بحوالي 5 مليار دينار
يعني
في اغسطس اب من عام 2021 برزت فكره اعاده
تفعيل خط الغاز الى الواجهه مدفوعه
بمستجدات سياسيه وجهد دولي لانقاذ لبنان
من العتمه
تقضي الخطه بتزويد لبنان بالكهرباء
الاردنيه وبنحو 660 مليون متر مكعب من
الغاز القادم عبر سوريا
ذهبنا الى دير عمار المحطه اللبنانيه
الوحيده المتصله بخط الغاز العربي
المعمل شغال حاليا على المازوت نحن عم
نستعمل هلا النفط اللي جيد ضمن الاتفاقيه
مع دوله العراق وعم بيجينا الكميه تقريبا
الربع الكميه اللي كانت تجينا من قبل
وبالتالي قبل ما يوصل الغاز الطبيعي نحن
حاليا عم نشتغل على المازوت بثلاث قدره
المعمل وعم بتكون تقريبا بتوازي نص الطاقه
اللي موجوده على الشبكه حاليا هيدي الطاقه
اللي على الشبكه عم تعطي المواطنين بحدود
ثلاث ساعات والادره الانتاجيه الحاليه يلي
برجع بقول التلت عم تعطي للمواطنين عم
يحسوا بها التغذيه اذا وصل لغاز الطبيعي
انه المعمل يشتغل بكامل طاقته ويعطي بحدود
الاكتشافات الجديده في شرق البحر المتوسط
وخصوصا الحقل زهر المصري الذي اكتشف في
المياه الاقتصاديه المصريه قد بكر مصر
ان ترفع
احتياطيها من الغاز الى اكبر كميه في
افريقيا نسبيا واصبحت مصر قادره على تصدير
الغاز من جديد للاردن كما انها قادره على
تصدير الغاز اذا احتاجت سوريه الى ذلك
وبالطبع عن طريق الخط الذي يربط بين مدينه
حمص السوريه ومدينه طرابلس اللبنانيه ولكن
كما قلت عندما نصل الى هذا الوضع الحالي
هناك ظروف سياسيه
واقتصاديه وتكنولوجيه تؤخر حدوث ذلك
تصطدم امال وضع المشروع حيز التنفيذ وجهود
مبادره اعاده تفعيل خط الغاز العربي بجمله
من العقبات من بينها شح الموارد الماليه
والتحديات التقنيه امام تاهيل الخط لكن
العقبات السياسيه وابرزها قانون قيصر الذي
اقره الكونغرس الامريكي عام 2019 هي
التحدي الاكبر امام تصدير الغاز من مصر
عبر الاردن وسوريا الى لبنان ينص القانون
على معاقبه الشركات والافراد الذين يقدمون
التمويل او المساعده للنظام السوري في عده
قطاعات ومن بينها الطاقه ويشمل ذلك
المساعده في صيانه او توسيع انتاج النظام
للغاز الطبيعي والمنتجات البتروليه
تحديات التي تواجه تدفئه الغاز والكهرباء
الى سوريا ولبنان تتمثل في تحدي سياسي
وتحدي مالي تحدي سياسي انه كما هو معروف
في قانون قيصر وبالتالي انه في قانون
المقاطعه حقيقه انه كان في جهود من
الحكومه الاردنيه وكانت هناك وعود من
الجانب الامريكي الا انه يبدو ان بعدنا تم
توقيع الاتفاقيه بين الاطراف الاربعه
الاردن ومصر والسوريه ولبنان تم اعلان على
انه البنك الدولي لم يوافق على تمويل
لبنان بتغطيه غلاف استيراد الطاقه
الكهربائيه من الاردن وكلها استيراد الغاز
فبالتالي هذا التحدي الرئيسي الكبير
نعرف ان اتفاق الغاز المصري
والكهرباء من الاردن
حاله دون استكماله عقبات سياسيه وتتعلق
بالبنك الدولي وبقانون قيصر وكنا ناطرين
من فتره لفتره وكان واضح انه في حاله
تسويف وتردد
بلد تمويل ما حدا رح يقبل يعطينا غاز من
دون ما يكون مامن على انه دفع له بالاخر
التمويل هو راح يكون عبر البنك الدولي
البنك الدولي تيقدر يوافق على التمويل في
عنا كذا شرط لازم يكون مطابق وبده عم يطلب
ينعمل تدقيق مالي تدقيق بيئي وتدقيق
اجتماعي للمعمل ولخط الغاز اكيد صار في
تدقيق بمؤسسه كهرباء لبنان بالنسبه للربح
والخساره كان عم ينشغل على الموضوع المعمل
كمان تم تكليف شركه وجاء وفن البنك الدولي
عملوا بدهم يشوفوا الاثر البيئي على
المعمل قبل الغاز قبل الوصول الغاز وبعده
وصول الغاز وفي كمان بيهتم بالبنك الدولي
بالتدقيق الاجتماعي شو شو الاثر على
المحيط اللي بالمعمل اجتماعيه هلا هذه
الامور كلها سواء بتدخل بالعقد شراء الغاز
طبيعي تكون واضحه للونك الدولي فهو يوافق
على على التمويل
اذا لم تنتهي المفاوضات
وتتوفر الظروف
للتعاون باطار مشروع
الغاز المصري والكهرباء من الاردن سوف
نعود الى وضع اسوا بكثير لم تحصل مصر
والاردن على ضمانات امريكيه تؤكد استثناء
المشروع من قانون قيصر ولم يتمكن لبنان من
اقناع البنك الدولي بالحصول على قرض
بمقدار 300 مليون دولار لتفعيل خط الغاز
مما يجعل مستقبل المشروع غامضا ويجمد امال
احيائه في منطقه ما زالت تعثر السياسي
والمعيشي سيد المشهد فيها
قبل اسبوع واجهه لبنان انقطاعا شاملا في
التيار الكهربائي بعد توقف محطتين عن
العمل نتيجه عدم تسديد جزء من مستحقاتها
الماليه وعاد التيار الكهربائي بعد تعهد
رئيس حكومه تصريف الاعمال نجم نقاط بتسديد
هذه المستحقات من حقوق السحب الخاص التي
حولها صندوق النقل الدولي الى البلاد وقد
اكد وزير الطاقه اللبناني وليد فياض اهميه
مشروع نقل الغاز المصري الى بلاده ممتع
استغرابه من رفض البنك الدموي الدولي عفوا
تمويله بذريعه دراسه الجدوى السياسيه
للمشروع واكد الوزير اللبناني ان حكومته
استجابت لكافه شروط البنك الدموي لتمويل
هذا المشروع مشيرا الى ان الامر يتطلب
دعما امريكيا ومن جهتهم يقول الامريكيون
انهم ينتظرون العقود النهائيه لمشروعي
امداد لبنان بالغاز والكهرباء
للتاكد من توافقها مع السياسه الامريكيه
ومعالجه مخاوف محتملات تتعلق بالعقوبات
وقد بدات الخميس الماضي في الواقع عمل
التنقيب عن النفط والغاز في المنطقه
التاسعه من المياه البحريه جنوبيه لبنان
وتقول السلطات اللبنانيه انها متفائله
بوجود كميات من الغاز ستساعد البلاد في
النهوض من ازمتها الاقتصاديه بينما تحذر
جهات محليه من العجز عن اداره هذا القطاع
في ظل تحديات سياسيه واقتصاديه جمه لكن
ماذا عن مصر مورد الغاز الذي ينتظره
اللبنانيون تقارير اشارت الى تراجع انتاج
الغاز الطبيعي في مصر الى ادنى مستوى في
ثلاث سنوات خلال الاشهر الخمسه الاولى من
هذا العام وانخفضت قيمه صادرات مصر من
الغاز الطبيعي ومن الغاز المسال ايضا
بالنسبه تقارب السبعين في المئه على اساس
سنوي خلال مايو الماضي فزمن هذا مع اعلان
اسرائيل عزمها زياده صادراتها من الغاز
الى القاهره لزياده ايرادات الدوله وتعزيز
العلاقه السياسيه مع مصر
[موسيقى]
نرحب بكم مشاهدينا الكريمين وبضيفين
الكريمين من الكويت المهندس وائل حامد عبد
المعطي خبير اسواق الغاز والهيدروجين في
منظمه الاقطار العربيه المصدره للبترول
اوابيك ومن بريكسيل السيده لوريا مديره
معهد حوكمه الموارد الطبيعيه لمنطقه الشرق
الاوسط وشمال افريقيا اهلا بضيفينا
الكريمين نبدا معك مهندس وائل نتساءل عن
الاهميه
الاستراتيجيه
والاقتصاديه لخط الغاز العربي للدول التي
يمر منها كيف تراها
مساء الخير استاذه فيروز وبدايه شكرا
جزيلا على الدعوه
للمشاركه في برنامجكم المميز اللي القصه
بقيم عودا على على السؤال وهي الاهميه
الاقتصاديه والاهميه الاستراتيجيه الخط
الغاز العربي فلو عدنا الى تاريخ هذا الخط
في عام 2003 الحقيقه كان يشكل نقطه تحول
في قطاع البترول في مصر كبدايه لان مصر في
ذلك الوقت لم تكن دوله مصدره للغاز
الطبيعي ومكنها خط الغاز العربي من دخول
نادي الدول المصدره للغاز الطبيعي في عام
2003 بعد محققت مجموعه من الاكتشافات في
منطقه البحر المتوسط والصحراء الغربيه
نجحت مصر انها ترفع معدلات انتاجها
المحليه وتلبيه الطالب المحلي وتحقيق فائض
ساهم في التصدير الى الدول المجاوره زي
الاردن عبر خط الغاز العربي وايضا ازاله
الغاز الطبيعي
من استخدام بعض المنشات اللي تم انشائها
فيما بعد في منطقه دمياط وايادكو فمن
الجانب الاقتصادي الجانب المصري بشكل كبير
استفاد من ايرادات مبيعات الغاز اللي قام
بتصديرها بدايه من عام 2003 الى الجانب
الاردني وتزايدت بشكل تدريجي حتى وصلت الى
اقصى قيمه لها في عام 2010 ما يعادل حوالي
2.5 مليار متر مكعب سنويا كذلك نجح
الطرف المصري او الجانب المصري في ضخ
الغاز كما اشرطه في الوثائقي ما قبل
التقديم نجح في زياده او تصدير الغاز الى
جانب السوري بموجه تفاهمات بين الجانبين
ووصل ايضا الغاز المصري الى الجانب
اللبناني بموجب اتفاق ما بين الاطراف ما
بين الجانب المصري والاردني والسوري
واللبناني فمن حيث القيمه الاقتصاديه كل
الدول المشاركه على هذا الخط استفادت
الجانب المصري استفاد من مبيعات الغاز
الجانب الاردني والسوري واللبناني استفاد
ايضا من الحصول على وقود في ذلك الوقت كان
وقود رخيص الثمن و الى حد كبير طبعا بيكون
تاثيره على البيئه مقارنه بالمنتجات
البتروليه السائله
هذه الاهميه الاقتصاديه لو
ساعود اليك مهندس وائل لكن دعني اتساءل
نعم ساعود اليك الى نقاط متعدده لكن دعني
اتحول السيده لوري ونسالها عن الجانب
اللبناني
الان يعني الى اي مدى يمكن باعتقادك ان
يرسم هذا المشروع مشروع خط الغاز العربي
في حل مشاكل لبنان المستعصيه خاصه فيما
يخص الطاقه والكهرباء ان هو اكتمل او اعيد
تفعيله
مشكله لبنان ولكن جزئيا قد كان يحل
المشكله لانه عندما عرض على لبنان موضوع
نقل الغاز من مصر الى لبنان عبر الخط
العربي كانت كان نتكلم عن ثلاث او اربع
ساعات في النهار عندما لم يكن لبنان
يستطيع ان يؤمن
اي ساعه وبالتالي كنا كنا نتكلم عن ثلاث
او اربع ساعات في النهار وبالتالي لم يكن
هو الحال كان جزء من الحلول التي كانت
تحاول البعد البلدان المحيطه المجاوره
والامريكيين والفرنسيين كانوا يحاولون
مساعده لبنان بطريقه ما وكان هذا جزء من
الحل للمشكله ولكن كنا نعرف نعلم جميعا ان
هذه لن تحل المشكله وان 300,000 300 مليون
دولار سنويا كانت فقط لمجرد اعطاء اربع
ساعات من الكهرباء للبنان للبنانيين وهذا
ما لم يكن طموح اللبنانيين طبعا وكان سوف
يكون هذا عبء اضافي وديول اضافيه على
لبنان ولكن لن تكن لن تكن سوف تحل مشكله
اللبنانيين في حينها عندما كانوا يعانون
الكثير
للقطاع التام للكهرباء واضافه الى الغلاء
للمولدات الطبيعيه
التي ارتفعت اسعارها بطريقه جنونيه بهذه
بتلك الفتره وطبعا تستمر
بالاسعار الجنونيه وارتفاع الاسعار
الجنونيه اضافه اليوم طبعا بارتفاع سعر
الكهرباء ايضا سعر الكهرباء التي تؤامنه
شركه كهرباء لبنان حتما هذا المشروع
الغاز العربي ما كان ليحل كل مشاكل لبنان
لكنه كان سيسد ولو جزءا من هذا الموضوع
رغم ذلك البنك الدولي رفض تمويل عمليه
استخدام هذا الغاز المصري الى لبنان الامر
الذي استهجنه واستهجنته الطبقه السياسيه
اللبنانيه والحكومه اللبنانيه وزير الطاقه
اعلن بانه تم تنفيذ كل الشروط التي وضعها
البنت لكن رغم ذلك
لم يتم الاستجابه هل هناك مطالبات سياسيه
من لبنان نتساءل ما السبب حقيقه لان هناك
احاديث عن شرطين تحديدا متعلقين بالتدقيق
حسابات كهرباء لبنان والبدء بتشكيل الهيئه
الناظمه
الكهرباء يعني ما الذي يمكن قوله فيما يخص
هذين الشرطين وهل تم استيفاء جميع الشروط
والى اين وصلت المفاوضات الى الان
ان هنالك هنا جزئين من الشروط كان هنالك
موضوع السياسي وكان موضوع عقوبات اذا بدنا
نقول قيصر
وهذه المشكله لم تكن مشكله لبنانيه مئه في
المئه لانه على لبنان فعل كل ما يريده الا
طرف الامريكي من تاكيد على العقود
ليتمكنوا من من وزاره الخزينه الامريكيه
ان تتاكد ان هذه العقود لن تفيد الجانب
السوري وخاصه النظام الرئيس بشار الاسد
ولكن كانت هنالك مشكله عند الاردنيه ولا
السوريين والمصريين الذين لم يحصلوا على
الضمانات التي كانوا يريدونها من الاداره
الامريكيه ليتمكنوا من التنفيذ بهذه
النقطه مهمه
ساعود اليك شق السياسي والنقطه الثانيه في
لبنان
النقطه المتعلقه كانت في لبنان كانت اكثر
متعلقه بالاصلاحات المطلوبه بقطاع
الكهرباء وكلنا نعرف انه منذ منذ فتره
المجتمع الدولي كان يطالب بالاصلاحات في
قطاع الكهرباء ليتمكن من اعطاء الاموال
للبنان ورصد الاموال اللي لبنان وفشل
لبنان في الهيئه الناظمه لم يؤسس للهيئه
الناظمه المجلس المجلس الاداره مجلس اداره
كهرباء لبنان كان مجلس سياسي اكثر منه
مجلس كفاءات وهنالك تعيينات كانت تعينات
سياسيه وبالتالي الجزء فقط الذي قامت فيه
الدوله اللبنانيه هاي زياده التعريفه ولكن
الكل كان يعرف ان زياده تعرف لن تكون هي
الفص البند الاصلاحي ولم يحصل اي شيء
بالنسبه للجبايه ونحن نعرف ان 30% من
الخسائر التي كانت تتكبدها شركه كاربال
لبنان كانت بسبب عدم الجبايه وبسبب كانت
تحصل على الشبكه وبالتالي السلطات
اللبنانيه فقط ركزت على موضوع رفع
التعريفه على المواطنين وبدون اخص بعاني
الاعتبار الجنود الاصلاحيه الاخرى
وبالتالي تاخرت كثيرا الحكومه اللبنانيه
في الاصلاحات ولم تفعل جميع الاصلاحات
حينها الاموال المرصده من قبل البنك
الدولي كانت قد حلت وبالتالي بنك الدوله
قرر ان هذه هذا المرصود بدل ان يذهب الى
الشقه الكهرباء فضلوا ان يساعدوا
يعني ان يقوم بمساعدات للمجتمع اللبناني
لانه في حينه مع المماطله التي كانت تقوم
فيها الحكومه اللبنانيه بالاصلاحات
وبالنهوض الاقتصادي كان هناك فكر متقع في
لبنان وبالتالي فان قالت فضل البنك الدولي
ان يرصد هذه الاموال الى المجتمع
بالفعل هناك طبعا ازمه ثقه في الطبقه
السياسيه اللبنانيه ساعود الى هذه وكيف
اثرت في موضوع الطاقه ايضا لكن انت اشرت
الى نقطه مهمه السيده لوري اتحول بها الى
ضيفنا الكريم المهندس وائل متعلقه
بالعقبات السياسيه اشرت بشكل صريح لقانون
قيصر وطلب الاردن ومصر ايضا لضمانات فيما
يخص هذا الموضوع مصر طالبه بضمانات حتى لا
تقع الشركات المصريه تحت طائره العقوبات
للمتعاملين ربما وفق هذا القانون سؤال
المهندس وائل هل قدمت بالفعل هذه الضمانات
لمصر ما الذي نعرفه بهذا الخصوص
في الحقيقه وحتى هذه اللحظه لم تحصل او لم
يحصل الجانب المصري على ضمانات حقيقيه
وكلى المشكلتين سواء مشكله قانون قيصر او
مشكله البنك الدولي خلينا نقول للمشكلتين
ماشيين جنبا الى جنب يعني لا لا حصلنا على
ضمانات حقيقيه بعدم وقوع الشركات المصريه
كما اشارتي تحت طائله العقوبات انقاموا
بدخل غاز مباشره الى الجانب السوري ومنه
الى الجانب اللبناني وكذلك ايضا كان البنك
الدولي اعطى اشارات خلينا نقول بين قوسين
اشارات واضحه
لعدم قناعته بما قام به لبنان من اصلاحات
داخليه خاصه فيما يتعلق بعمليه التدقيق
على قطاع الكهرباء او زياده تعريفات
الكهرباء فحتى هذه اللحظه بتقديري بان
الوضع الحالي لا يزال يعني محلك سر او
مازال متوقف في نفس النقطه لم نحصل على
ضمانات او لم يحصل لجانب المصري على
ضمانات ومن ناحيه اخرى لم يمول او لم يعطي
البنك الدولي اشاره واضحه
هو اللي يتحمل تكلفه استج الغاز من مصر
واضح جدا في ظل هذا يعني
[موسيقى]
عدم وجود افق لاي حل وفي ظل الوضع
المستعصي في لبنان وفي ظل ان هذا الغاز
يمكن ان يحل كما ذكر السيده لوري جزء من
هذه المعضله اللبنانيه هل يمكن بالفعل
ربما ان تقدم او تقدم مصر على تسويه ما مع
لبنان الى حين ان يتم البث فيما يخص موضوع
صندوق النقد الدولي او عفوا البنك الدولي
والحصول على هذه التمويل هذا التمويل
لعمليه انشاء هذا الخط
يعني من جانب عملي او منطقي هو في الوقت
الحالي وانا حابب برضو اؤكد على هذه
النقطه لان خط الغاز العربي بالفعل هو
بيعمل هو ده غير متوقف ولكن مش كل الاطراف
مستفيده احنا بنتكلم هنا او النهارده على
تركيز على الجانب السوري او الجانب
اللبناني لكن الحقيقه الجانب الاردني
بيحصل بشكل او باخر على كميات من الغاز من
مصر تقريبا بتقدر بحوالي 1 مليون متر مكعب
في اليوم يعني تقريبا 365 مليون متر مكعب
في السنه فهو الخط يعمل ولكن هو بيغذي
الجانب الاردني ربما هذه المرحله ااا مصر
تجد تغذيه الجانب الاردني بهذا القدر وان
كان ضئيل او اقل مما كان عليه وقت تشييد
الخط في عام 2003 ولكن مساهم مع مصر بشكل
او باخر في تصدير كميه من الغاز الى
الجانب الاردني امر اخر وده في غايه
الاهميه يعني احنا ااا نظرتنا دايما لخط
الغاز العربي بان مصر هي الدوله الكبرى
المصدره وجميع الاطراف اللي موجوده على
الخط هي الاطراف المستورده الحقيقه ان خط
الغاز العربي داخل ايضا المنظور من داخل
الرؤيه المصريه تم التعامل معها ايضا كخط
يعني مورد للغاز الى مصر لان مصر مؤخرا
وربما من شهرين تقريبا وقعت الحكومه
المصريه ممثله في شركه ايجاز مع الجانب
الاردني ممثلا في شركه كهربائي الاردن
اتفاقيه لعمل خط هذا العربي بشكل عكسي
بحيث ان الاردن تستقبل على سبيل المثال
الغاز الطبيعي المسالم من السوق العالمي
لان لديها البنيه الاساسيه لذلك وضخ الغاز
الى مصر في حاله احتاجت مصر الى هذا الغاز
سواء اود ان ابقى معك في هذه النقطه فيما
يخص الموضوع الانتاج توريد وتصدير في مصر
فهي ترى مصدره للغاز ثم اصبحت تستورد
الغاز الطبيعي ثم باتت تنتج وتصدر وتستورد
لتعيد التصدير يعني نود ان نفهم هل الامر
موسمي ام يخضع لحسابات اخرى لو شرحتها لنا
طيب هو بدايه لتفكيك المشهد بشكل مبسط
الطلب على الغاز ليس طلب ثابت على مدار
شهور السنه المنطقه العربيه ومنها طبعا
بطبيعه الحال جمهوريه مصر العربيه بيكون
هناك ذروه في الطلب عاده بتكون في فتره
شهور الصيف بسبب زياده الاحمال الكهربائيه
نتيجه طبعا احتياج القطاع السكني الى الى
المكيفات والى ما شابه في العكس على فكره
في منطقه اوروبا بيكون ذروه الطلب في فصل
الشتاء
فالمشكله بتظهر او او بدايه ظهور المشكله
اللي بتظهر لما بيكون في زياده في الطلب
في ذروه الطلب في فتره شهور الصيف وعدم
كفايه الانتاج المحلي هنا في الحاله دي
بتبقى الدوله كاول اجراء بتاخده بتوقف
عمليه تصدير ال ان جي او الغاز الطبيعي
المسائل من خلال المنشات الاساله وده
بيبقى حتى معلن بشكل رسمي بان مصر بتوقف
عمليه تحميل شحنات الغاز الطبيعي المسال
من خلال منشاتها اللي موجوده في دمياطكو
لما بنيجي ندخل الى فتره او فصل الشتاء
بيكون اللي طلب على الطاقه الكهربائيه في
اقل معدلات العام فبيبقى الانتاج المحلي
بشكل او باخر بيكفي تلبيه الطلب المحلي
وبيكون في فائض بتستطيع الدوله من خلال
اداره مواردها توجيده الى محطات الاساله
في المجمل بنجد يعني هي عمليه طلب موسمي
هي اللي بتؤثر على قرار الدوله يصدر او
يستورد في هذه المرحله اعود مره اخرى
السيده لوري والوضع في لبنان
المعاقد اشارتي منذ قليل لقانون قيصر الذي
ابدت الولايات المتحده الاداره الامريكيه
بعض المرونه فيما يخصه وننتظر الان ربما
تبعات ذلك الموضوع ليس مكتملا بشيء بشكل
نهائي لكن ماذا عن التفاعلات والتجاذبات
السياسيه الداخليه في لبنان خاصه مع ازمه
الثقه ثقه المواطن اللبنانيه في الطبقه
السياسيه برمتها
اعتقد فقط لنفصل كمان انه بموضوع هذا
الموضوع المشروع انا اعتقد هذا المشروع
مات واليوم لم يعد
الكثير يتكلمون عنه خاصه انه هنالك كما
قال ضيفك هنالك هنالك يعني اذا بدك مشكله
انتاج من الناحيه المصريه وبالتالي اليوم
مصر تعاني من الانتاج ومن الاستهلاك وكل
من تتجه تستهلكه وهي تسعى جاهده الى
الزياده في الانتاج وانها وهي تعطي الرخص
الى الشركات العالميه لتبحث عن عن
الاكتشافات الجديده التي تقوم بحجم ظهر
واكبر لتستطيع ان يكون لديها فائض لتستطيع
بيعه بيعه الى الدول الاخرى وبالتالي
اليوم الفائض الوحيد الذي ياتي الى السوق
المصري هو الغاز الاسرائيلي الذي يضغط الى
الاسواق حسب الاتفاق ات الموجوده بين مصر
واسرائيل وبالتالي هذا الوحيد الموجود
اعتق لبنان سيطلب ربما ضمانات بان لا يكون
هذا الغاز باي طريقه او باخرى يعني قادما
من اسرائيل او فيه شبهه من هذا النوع
سيدتي لا اعرف انه اذا هنالك الضمانات قد
تعطى في هذا الشان على ما هو الالغاز خاصه
اذا الغاز الاسرائيلي يدخل الى البنى
التحتيه المصريه فقد تكون هنالك صعوبه في
معرفه مصدر الغاز الا اذا كانوا هنالك
طريقه اعتمدتها الدوله اللبنانيه مع
الدوله المصريه على هذا الموضوع ولكن انا
اعتقد اليوم
انتهى هذا المشروع
لن يكون هنالك الكلام خاصه اننا ندخل
اليوم الى انتخابات امريكيه رئاسيه وهذا
الموضوع كان حتى جاذب بين جمهوريين
وديمقراطيين في حينه عندما كانت هنالك
الانتخابات التمهيديه واستشرس الجمهوريين
على هذا المشروع وكانوا هنالك كل يوم
تقارير تكون ان هذا المشروع سوف يفيد نظام
بشار الاسد اليوم نحن نرى انه هنالك عوده
تطبيع عربي مع النظام السوري ولكنه في ذات
الوقت اليوم ان هنالك بعض الاصوات التي
عادت ترتفع في سوريا والامريكيين ليسون
ليسوا بفاديحين بالتطبيع وبالتالي اعتقد
ان تجاذب الديمقراطي الجمهوري سيعود على
هذا الملف وبالتالي اليوم اصبحت الامور
معقده اكثر ولا اعتقد انه قريبا سوف يصل
اي غاز من مصر الى هذا المشروع بالنسبه لك
سيده لوريا وتتوقعين ان يعني ينتهي ولا
يكون له اي تاثير ما بدا اللبنان هل ما
يتم الحديث عنها عن عمليات تنقيب يمكن ان
تكون بديلا وما استقفل الزمني حتى نرى
نتائجها على المواطن اللبناني يعني
رئيس مجلس النواب اللبناني نبيه بري يتوقع
ان تظهر هذه النتائج خلال بضعه اشهر الى
اي مدى ذلك واقعي
صحيح النتائج نتائج الحفر الاستكشافي تظهر
من هنا الى اخر السنه وهذا يعني انه الحفل
الاستكشافي الذي يحصل حاليا في البلوك 9
في جنوب لبنان سوف هو للبحث عن النفط او
عن الغاز وبالتالي بعد ثلاثه اشهر قد تاتي
النتيجه على ثلاث سيناريوهات قد يكون
هنالك اي شيء وقد يكون البئر لا يحتوي على
نفط او غاز او قد يكون هنالك كميات قليله
جدا غير قابله للتطوير والانتاج او قد
يكون هنالك كميات قابله للتطوير والانتاج
في هذه الحاله اذا كل المكتشف هو داخل
المنطقه الاقتصاديه اللبنانيه حينها يطبق
على هذا
الاكتشاف التجاري المحتمل يطبق عليه العقد
المبرر بين لبنان وشركات توتال انرجي وقطر
للطاقه
ولكن اذا هذا الغاز المحتمل المكتشف
والتجاري قد يكون بين لبنان واسرائيل
علينا تطبيق اتفاق ترسيم الحدود لبنان
واسرائيل الذي يقول انه على توتال الشركه
المشغله ان تقوم باتفاق مالي مع اسرائيل
على حصه اسرائيل من المكتشف وبعد ذلك
يستطيع لبنان تطوير وانتاج الغاز هذه من
ناحيه ناحيه ثانيه الاكتشاف قد يحصل الان
ولكن موضوع الانتاج هو ياخذ الكثير من
الوقت
ايضا وبالتالي هذا سوف ياخذ الكثير من
الوقت يعني سوف ياخذ من خمس يمكن قد ياخذ
بين خمسه وسبع سنوات ولا اعتقد اللبنانيون
يستطيعون ان ان يعني يتحملوا ممتاز واضح
جدا لا يكون لديه 24 ساعه من الكهرباء
لسبع سنوات بعد
اعود مره اخرى المهندس وائل السيد اللوري
تقول بان هذا المشروع ان لم يكن ميتا الان
فمصيره ان ينتهي اود ان اعرف وجهه نظرك ما
رايك في هذا الموضوع بدايه
وباعتقادك يعني مستقبل خط الغاز العربي
واسواق الطاقه في المنطقه برمتها كيف
ستتاثر بهذه الاكتشافات نتحدث عن البلوك
تسعه في المياه الاقليميه جنوب لبنان
وهناك ما يتحدث عن مستقبل هائل في مجال
الغاز الطبيعي خاصه في لبنان وسوريا وفق
تقارير دوليه
استاذه فيروز هو خليني اجاوب من الشق
الاخر او الشق الثاني من من السؤال او
الجزء التاني وهو متعلق بالجانب اللبناني
الحقيقه احنا في منظمه الاوبك خلينا دراسه
منشوره بقاله اكتر من سبع سنوات وضعنا
فيها تصور
لمقدرات لبنان المحتمله من الغاز الطبيعي
بناء على نتائج دراسات المسح السيزمي اللي
قامت لبنان
باجراءها على مدارات اكثر من عقلين وخلينا
تقديرات مبدئيه استنادا لنتائج اللي كانت
طالعه في نتائج البحث السيزمي ومقارنتها
مع نتائج المسح السيزمي امام سواحل قبرص
بان لبنان من يعني احنا بنقول محتمل ان
يكون لديه مخزون من الغاز يقدر بحوالي 25
تريليون قدم مكعب في الرقع رقم تسعه لكن
عمليه ترجمه
لان دي برده احيانا بيبقى احنا مش فاهمين
السقف الزمني للمراحل احنا بنبدا الاول
بمسح سيزمي يعقدها مرحله الحفر الاستكشافي
ودي اللي بتقوم بيه الشركات العالميه
امثال اني وتوتال وقطر بتروليام ثم مرحله
توصيف الكشف بمعنى ان انا اقدر اعرف حجمه
قد ايه ثم بيتحول الكشف الى كشف تجاري
بمعنى اللي بيكون اتفاقيه للانتاج هذه
العمليه عمليه طويله هي ربما فقط في مصر
كانت حاله استثنائيه في اكتشاف حقل ظهر
استطاعت انها تترجم من عمليه الاستكشاف
الى انتاج الحقل حوالي سنتين ونصف وده
يعتبر يعني يعني جدول زمني مضغوط للغايه
لان مصر كانت في حاجه اه كان في حاجه ماسه
شديده جدا وكان في ضغط سياسي للاصراع
بالانتاج لبنان في الوقت الحالي تاكيدا
برده على نفس الجزئيه لا يملك بنيه تحتيه
لمعالجه الغاز او مستقبل الغاز
تماما واشارت الى ان المده الزمنيه التي
قد يتطلبها المشروع هي سنوات واشارت الى
سقفه بمقادي يصل الى سبع سنوات
لكن هي النتائج يعني من حيث المحتمل هناك
التقديرات مبدئيه بان يكون في حوالي 25
تريليون على اقل تقدير تريليون ادم مكعب
من الغاز بناء على نتائج المسح السيزمي
وفي معلومه ممكن نشرها النهارده نفس
الشركات اللي قامت بعمليات البحث عن الغاز
قبال السواحل قبرص هي هي نفس الشركات اللي
قامت بعمليات المسح السيزمي قبال السواحل
لبنان في المنطقه الاقتصاديه الخالصه منذ
اكثر من عشر سنوات وقبرص تعتبر متقدمه
نوعا ما مقارنه طبعا بلبنان لانها حققت
اكثر من 5 اكتشافات بسبب وجود عدد كبير من
الشركات العالميه فاحنا بنقول ان في تصنيف
خزانات الغاز نفس الشركه اللي عملت المسح
هنا هي اللي عملت هنا وتقريبا الجيولوجيه
الموجوده في نفس المنطقه ما بين قبرص
ولبنان تقريبا متشابهه وبناء عليه بيكون
فيه احتماليه نتائج مباشره للبنان اما
عودا على الجزء الاولاني من السؤال وان ان
المشروع ربما لن يكتب له النجاح او يعني
احنا هنا برده حصرين عمليه تصدير الغاز
المصري الى الجانب اللبناني الحياه مصر في
حد ذاتها كان ليها اكتر من اعلان رسمي
بانها ترغب انها تكون مركز لتجاره الغاز
وعشان تتمكن اي دوله مش بس مصر اي دوله
تعلن انها ترغب انها تكون مركز تداول او
تجاره لابد تتحقق فيها مجموعه من الشروط
وهنشوف ساعتها هل الخط الغاز العربي هينفع
ولا لا اول شرط ان يكون في بنيه تحتيه
لدينا خطوط انابيب لدينا مرافق لتخزين
لدينا محطات للاساله رقم اثنين وجود اكتر
من مصدر الامدادات الغاز داخل مركز
التجاره على فكره ليس بالضروري ان الدوله
تكون منتجه للغاز عشان تكون مركز تجاره
مركز تجاره معناها ان الدوله لديها مصدر
للانتاج وده موجود في حاله مصر ولديها
ايضا القدره على استجلاب الغاز من اكثر من
مصدر اخر وده ليه يعني فلسفه من ناحيه
اساسيات السوق ان ما يكونش هناك احتقار
لانتاج الغاز لدى شركه او شركات بعينها
داخل السوق المحلي في الدوله التي ترغب في
انشاء هذا المركز فنجد ان في الحاله
المصريه يوجد انتاج محلي ربما في تراجع
كما اشرت في بدايه تقريرك لكن هو بند من
بنود امدادات الغاز في مصر هناك اتفاقيات
مع بعض الدول بتسمح باستجلاب الغاز الى
مصر هناك اتفاقيات محتمل ايضا مع الجانب
القبرصي ربما تساهم في استجلاب الغاز الى
مصر هو ده مفهوم فكره مركز تجاره مركز
تجاره معناها ان انا عندي قدره انتج وعندي
قدره استورد واقدر في الاخر اعيد توجيه
هذه الكميات منها القيمه المضافه
تتوافر هذه المقاومه نعم صحيح لذلك انا
ارى ان خط الغاز العربي هيساهم في هذا
الامر لان خط الغاز العربي مش هنحصره في
فقط في التصدير لبنان انا قلت اللي ممكن
اخذت الغاز العربي في حد ذاته يكون اداه
الاستجلاب الغاز من الاردن الاردن تملك
بنيه اساسيه لاستيراد الغاز الطبيعي
المسائل لديها في ميناء العقبه مرفق عائم
هي سفينه بتستقبل النقلات بيتم تفريغ
الغاز المسال وتغويزه وضخه في الشبكه
تستطيع مصر وقد مضت الدفاع بالفعل في
يونيو اه تقدر تستجري بالغاز وبالتالي هنا
يحقق المفهوم الاشمل لاستغلال خط الغاز
العربي من المنظور المصري كمركز تجاره اذا
من الموضوع المصري ستصبح مركز لتجاره
الغاز السيده لوري يقول ضيفنا الكريم
المهندس وائل وان هذا المشروع يعني سيستمر
حتى وان لم يستفد منه لبنان كما ذكرتي
الان سؤالي لك ان لم يستفد لبنان من مشروع
خط الغاز العربي وان كان موضوع التنقيب
يعني امامه سنوات طويله حتى يرى المواطن
اللبناني اثاره ايه حلول الان ما البدائل
على المدى القصير الان باعتقادك لمشكله
الطاقه والكهرباء المزمن في لبنان
على المدى القصير ليس هنالك من حل
جذري يعني ومستدام كل ما تفعله اليوم
الحكومه اللبنانيه انها تستمر بالاستدانه
من بنك المركزي
لتستطيع ان تشتري الف يو الاول من
العراق لتستطيع ان تمد الفيول لشركات شركه
كهرباء لبنان لتستطيع ان تدير المعامل
والمعامل لا تستطيع ان تعمل على على يعني
على قدراته القصوى لانها لا تاتي بالكميات
الكميه بالفيول لانه هي هذا يعتمد على
الاموال التي يجب ان ترصدها الحكومه
اللبنانيه التي لا تملكها وتستدين منها في
كسلفه من الخزينه وبالتالي بعضنا في زفه
نفس المشكله التي كانت مستمره لسنوات
والتي زادت من من ديون الدوله
المتجدده باعتقادك نحن نرى ان
كنت جايتك بالحديث وبالتالي اليوم
بالمقابل المولدات الخاصه اصبحت هي ايضا
مكلفه جدا على المواطنين وبالتالي الذين
هم قادرون او البلديات التي قادره على وضع
الطاقات المتجدده ووضع
السولارز هذا اللي عم تعمله وبالتالي
اليوم المواطن اللبناني يسعى الى اتخاذ
الحلول ان يبتكر الحلول من نفسه لانه لا
يستطيع ان يتكل على ويعتمد على الحكومه
اللبنانيه وعلى شركه كهرباء لبنان
وبالتالي اليوم نرى ان هنالك استعمال
للطاقات المتجدده وخاصا للطاقه الشمسيه
وكما تقول الدوله في قبل الازمه كنا 100
ميجاوات فقط من الانتاج كان من الطاقه
الشمسيه وكانت اكثرها مدعومه من الدوله
اللبنانيه اليوم اصبحنا حوالي 1000
ميجاوات وكلها اكثريتها هي
من انشاء الناس
مصروف الناس موجوده
واضح تماما اشكرك جزيل الشكر للاسف وقتنا
انتهى تماما لوري هياتان مديره معهد حوكمه
الموارد الطبيعيه لمنطقه الشرق الاوسط
وشمال افريقيا ضيفتنا الكريمه كنت معنا من
كما اشكر جزيل الشكر من الكويت المهندس
وائل حامد عبد المعطي خبير اسواق الغاز
والهيدروجين في منظمه الاقطار العربيه
المصدره للبترول
القادم باذن الله مع بقيه بقصه جديده
السلام عليكم
[موسيقى]